Average True Range, or the ATR, is a commonly used technical indicator,
and it's primarily used as a measure of volatility in terms of pips or movements in price.
Now the calculation is in fact quite simple.
Firstly, let's define range.
Now the range is the difference between the lowest traded price
from the highest traded price in any given time period,
and is measured in pips.
Now the ATR averages out these ranges over a preset number of preceding time periods.
中最多的是1-4 套試.
現在的ATR會是螢光型、
那麵打完整以後,
加分度到超量下距離的ATR,
並出了兩倍速的提格,
中升降陷入和至少增加打下距離。
現在,市主要的時計是現時問題低達或是低ATR。
一旦問題消低提,或是用調強了達而定的攻撞,
會有壞到達到突破的雙方。
现在,这个平台的几乎可以使用时,当你会选择的几乎。
基本上,一传书可以使用几乎的几乎,
当你最选择的几乎是最选择的几乎。
所以,如果说,如果你会用一个长买买的几乎,
在一张几乎的几乎,
然后,当你当时的几乎是10,
你会用几乎的几乎,在三乎的几乎。
所以,这会是30匹几乎的几乎。
1.2535 would take a profit target of 1.2565
Conversely, you may place a stop at say 1.5X the ATR
so that would be a 15 pip stop loss
that would take you out at 1.2520
now the ATR is available for most broker platforms
so it's well worthwhile checking it out